tu d'installer dans ses volets saisir
l'instant vivre le présent c'est fear et
aînés en 2013 de la rencontre fait
d'aurélien et deux mois
on a très vite travailler ensemble sur
des compositions on a été rejoint
ensuite par valentin guitariste et
valentin nous a fait rencontrer ensuite
thomas qui est arrivé pour assurer la
basse au sein de au sein des filles
[Musique]
on vient de différents projets chacun
différents projets musicaux et on a eu
envie de voilà de reconstituer
d'affaires de partir sur de nouvelles
bases
dans un style à la pop rock qu'on a
tenté ensuite de différents autres
styles musicaux plus groove avec
l'arrivée notamment de de thomas et de
valentin et c'est l envi voilà de créer
quelque chose tous ensemble à 4 et avec
une base musicale qui nous tient à coeur
et aussi des textes une écriture en
français se baser sur des compositions
ça aussi c'était tout l'enjeu du projet
zéphyr et de et ensuite de tourner deux
voilà d'enregistrer de réaliser un clip
après par la suite qu'on va là on va
faire un peu plus tard mais chacun
apporte son vécu son expérience et c'est
vraiment très très enrichissant ça nous
a permis de beaucoup évolué en
s'écoutant en se comprenant aussi
musicalement et c'est vrai que ce que
tom apporte que valentin apporte ce
qu'aurélien porte
ben voilà c'est bénéfique pour le groupe
et pour l'unité qu'on a autour de zéphyr
parce que c'est vrai une unité
artistique il ya aussi une unité humaine
qui est là et qui est très important de
chez nous et ça fait aussi le le ciment
de du groupe
c'est ce qui nous permet aussi d'avancer
mais c'est vrai il a par le fait qu'on
s'aime beaucoup et que dès qu'on
s'entend bien quand on a passé beaucoup
de temps ensemble
maintenant en tout notre richesse
musicale entre des années 70 jusqu'au
jusqu'à des choses très moderne beaucoup
plus même technoïde moi j'ai fait
d'improvisation aussi donc toute cette
richesse de recherche dans les
mouvements jazz ou aux américains
attentes multiculturelles
et puis ben valentin girex et l'italie
le son des années 70 c'est clair et puis
le l'influencent aussi le john scofield
des choses qui sont tous plus structuré
triturer au niveau du son et puis
émotionnel avec une base
tu plus grandes dents plus plus
affranchis plus plus pop geste et en
plus plus plus simple simplifiée pour
parce que si on jouait du jazz tordue on
est mais c'est quoi ce truc là ça serait
pas du pop rock mélangent sa large
horizon c'est à ça que chez nous
j'espère qu'il manquait pas une cheville
c'est une bonne expérience pour nous on
a voilà c'était il y avait des groupes
aussi qui était talentueux à nos côtés
nous on a eu le
coup de coeur du jury coup de coeur
aussi du public août pour nous ça a été
vraiment
belle récompense
et puis ça nous a boostés aussi à encore
plus travailler aller plus de l'avant et
ça nous amène aujourd'hui dans ce studio
pour enregistrer le p qui pour nous est
une étape très importante et donc voilà
on est très heureux de pratiquer ce 30
le ferry turc